mariachi gbytes wing and lump the dreams
the screaming number had a license maria jesus
nones charro suits in your
plague fan they distract him and harass him story
light in fine the master
of charro suits jorge tico
the selection is nose mexico guatemala
[Music]
first  in first rock girl the charro
is the Mexican cowboy the cowboy a
charro suit is very important
to wear at parties whether it be weddings
fifteen years a very special event
whoever wears the charro suit uses it as a
military uniform it has to be worn with
a lot of respect for my desire for andy
sports isner is the master jorge
perhaps they are a name or a
very big support for me the truth is that I
deserve they may be outdoors in
these three indigent topics
suits permissions old world link they are
soluble and we made suits  for anthony
quinn gael garcía bernal diego luna
carlitos santana chevy chase and a man
that the truth is that I already forget so many and
who and once and for all
this topic is distracting partner
rest in this job you cannot use
modern equipment or machines because this
is a very delicate job it is a job
that has to be done by hand we even have
a granny pedal machine
I tell her because it is the machine where
we can  make the designs called
la greca and who saves mariachi in the
year you are already level jorge is level
waitz boyacá that is one of the
most popular neighborhoods in los angeles the most
you leave the store and see a mariachi with
the guitarrón another with the  trumpet another
with the violin you arrive at the square and they are
studying there here it is a world of
mariachi well
don't press that
mariachi monster pleasure reinfeldt mariachis
waiting félix mariachis arturo ramírez
arturo cold is severe the teacher the
teacher jorge tello is lucky to
have him here  in the neighborhood because he is
the one who makes us our suits and it
is something important for the community in
disuse al led morales sustain us well
hey for us  wearing the
charro suit is something that fills us with
pride we are representing our
core culture in English frank and it is
primary
jorge never wears it analysis of making
charro suits there is a celebrity from
mexico vicente fernández says vicente
until you stop clapping I'll
stop singing while the mariachis
come here to my god and hammer shout
future
[Applause]
[Music]